[Música]
actualizamos las noticias económicas con
Juan Pablo lucum y Juan Pablo saludo
nuevamente Buenos días Ángela vamos a
empezar con América Latina en este
segmento el brote de gripe ayer en Chile
que hizo que aumentaran los precios del
huevo y otros productos derivados de la
industria una noticia que la afecta a
usted me afecta a mí básicamente Porque
en ese lugar pues ya han enterrado más
de un millón de estas aves que ponían
huevos y básicamente pues esto ha
afectado el valor de este producto y de
sus derivados también según informes
oficiales de este país el precio de los
huevos ha subido un 35% esto en el
último año chile ha reportado casos de
gripe aviar
h5n1 desde finales del año pasado en
animales salvajes y las autoridades
sanitarias chilenas dijeron que el virus
puede transmitirse de aves o mamíferos a
humanos pero no se conoce todavía la
transmisión de persona a persona con
este brote las grandes industrias
hicieron que el gobierno detuviera las
exportaciones de aves de corral lo que
en realidad ha afectado el precio de
todo del mundo porque pues este es un
país exportador importante también se ha
detectado casos en Argentina pero Brasil
el mayor exportador mundial de aves de
corral se mantiene libre del contagio
escuchemos que dicen las autoridades
chilenas y los ciudadanos bueno en
planteles de huevos Van cinco planteles
de huevos afectados tres en bío-bío en
la región de biobío y dos en la región
del
maulevas Así que ahí estamos viendo qué
va a pasar con todo eso en la carne
también del apoyo también no sé cómo
será eso también evitado de comprar
porque me da susto porque tengo nieto y
es terrible eso que te pase algo y
continuamos con Pablo con el reporte de
pérdidas que dio a conocer el Republic
banglaron en más de 100 mil millones de
dólares en el primer trimestre de este
año lo que complicó las ganancias en
bolsa de la compañía ya que los
inversores esperaban un panorama mejor
para el banco la pérdida de los
depósitos procedió a pesar que el
prestamista obtuvo un salvavidas de 30
mil millones de dólares en depósitos
combinados de los pesos pesados
bancarios de Estados Unidos estamos
hablando de Bank of America
Morgan y Wells Fargo con esto concede en
San Francisco planea reducir su balance
general y recortar gastos mediante la
reducción de la compensación de
ejecutivos la reducción del espacio
administrativo y despidiendo a casi el
25% de los empleados en el segundo
trimestre de este año Te quiero pedir
por favor Los indicadores Y es que este
dato de pérdida que acabamos de dar
afectó definitivamente la apertura de
Wall Street que se dio hace unos pocos
minutos y abrió negativo con sus tres
principales indicadores en América
Latina hubo en términos generales un
cierre positivo los principales
indicadores de Perú Colombia México y
Argentina reportaron ganancias este
último el de Buenos Aires con una
ganancia que casi toca el 3% por segundo
día consecutivo y el único que reportó
pérdidas fue Sao Paulo de Brasil con una
caída del 0,40% en el sector bursátil
europeo los rendimientos cayeron Este
martes ya que los inversores se
mantuvieron nerviosos por el estado de
la economía antes de la decisión sobre
las tasas de interés en otros temas
Taiwán sigue firmando acuerdos
importantes pese a la presión ejercida
por China y esta vez fue el gobernador
del estado de Virginia de Estados Unidos
glenn quien se desplazó hasta taipei
firmó un acuerdo de cooperación
económica y comercial con Taiwán en el
lanzamiento de una misión comercial
hacia por parte del político que también
sería candidato a la presidencia de
Estados Unidos hoy con el dato Pues de
Joe biden confirmando su reelección el
gobernador de Virginia dijo que los
intereses de Estados Unidos estaban
relacionados con semiconductores
productos farmacéuticos cadenas de
suministro Automotriz y cadena de
suministro de energía esto en el marco
de la meta de Estados Unidos de querer
convertirse en uno de los grandes
productores de chips el del lado
occidental
y finalmente tenemos una cifra del día
que también está interesante Así es son
los dos coma cinco mil millones de
dólares que gastará Netflix en contenido
coreano para las nuevas producciones Y
es que las exportaciones culturales de
Corea del Sur que incluyen música
videojuegos y películas alcanzaron un
récord de 12.400 millones de dólares en
2021 según cifras del gobierno yo no sé
usted cómo le vaya con el contenido
surcoreano sabe que no me gusta tanto no
se acuerda del juego del calamar Sí pero
me angustia un poco Bueno pero van a
sacar más producción tiene que vérselas
pues vamos a tener la oportunidad al
menos de darles la prueba gracias a
usted Juan Pablo mañana con masacra